security it is on everyone's mind we're
talking strip safety to our schools even
our own homes reporter Brian will was at
the International Security conference
underway over the Venetian Convention
and Expo Center he joins us live right
near the strip to explain what is being
developed to keep us safe hey Brian
yeah guys security is top of mind for
all properties here on the Strip
protecting guests players employees and
even you and today Security Experts from
around the world gathered to share their
new ideas
a highly sophisticated robot that walks
just like a dog however Nicholas Noel
with Boston Dynamics says it's more
security conscious can walk around a
facility at night and you know check it
out make sure that Vehicles aren't where
they're not supposed to be people aren't
in the site when they're not supposed to
be it's just one of the many products
blending security and Technology at the
International Security conference and
run AI models to detect things before it
happens is what uh it's gonna where
security is going now
city is one of
one of Nate just one best overall new
product for their access control system
Mary Beth Shaughnessy is behind the
conference it is and it's extremely
important piece of the world today and
incorporating the latest and greatest
Technologies into your everyday life
tackling today's security issues with
new ideas like this gunshot detection
device that is already in use in a
handful of schools and businesses like
the Willis Tower in Chicago pick up the
phone and call 9-1-1 it takes about five
more minutes than if it's automated and
so our process automates it we detect it
automatically call First Responders get
them there on the scene faster these
events and that type of networking keeps
the industry connected it gets them
better prepared to help secure America
now some of those security trends that
you can start seeing in your everyday
life include more video surveillance and
AI technology reporting near the strip
Brian will 8 News Now